[Music]
in P to the rescue news oh thank you
word PP look is a P P is a wiener yeah
or you could go peepee I call wieners
wee-wee in Chinese isn't it but what
your wee-wee is your Butler
ah that's just my mom made that up Oh
she'll be like new touches but they do
if they they say come out the first time
she's like he's got such a big peepee
[Laughter]
haha she made up her own word yeah well
cuz it's people submitted by KFC zingers
our bomb I like fried chicken but KFC
like on the bottom of this fraction Thai
chicken Bell a woman allegedly set her
boyfriend on fire then put it out with a
bucket of urine
hmm where does she get the bucket
they're just sitting around yes that on
fire she had multiple plans to [ __ ] with
the dude and she went with a fire but he
was Plan B she'd have to sit and pee in
a bucket to throw it on him my friends
uncle had a pee collection my brother's
mother sisters cousins oh I'm seriously
so so back in the day I used to play at
my friend's house in the backyard and we
would play and then when it was time for
me to pee like I'll go over to the
corner he goes no no no he got to save
that pee I don't know why so yeah what a
perfect I want to watch you peanut mason
jars so what what his uncle had was all
these big you know those five-gallon
buckets that you get from Home Depot of
like former white paint
there's just buckets of pee in there and
I think he uses for fertilizers oh so
what am I thinking baby or one of them
was ha ha come on past full so I heated
it to help them by China and but I would
open the lids of the other ones they've
been seeing it for a long time and they
don't really right I mean like rot I
didn't like put that on somebody's skin
not health not a theme all in their
gonna amazing penis
why did your mama to go over to this
[ __ ] uncle's house that's all the
creep what I mean uncle green no the
uncle wasn't watching me pee yeah I
think I thought that he wasn't good for
planet our dog pissed at least I was
[ __ ] me
they had wonderful if you pee directly
on the plant but what are you doing it
dumping to the soil
woody take a poo I feel like it lied to
you dude really
yeah but I thought I thought uncle get
like a little scooper and then pour it
around the plants like on the on the
dirt how bad you ask me it's not pretty
bad smells pretty
I bet you were bombed I think we'll make
some balls kid could my grandma still
till this day talks about using human
[ __ ] for farming she like back in the
day everybody used human [ __ ] and the
best vegetables came out from the humans
nowadays thing is use a cow and all this
stuff but the human poop though like I'm
like I never heard anybody talk about
human [ __ ] so deliciously you know like
oh if that's your mission but that
everybody thought of getting hepatitis
in Asia so that we don't do that no more
and all the exam okay that's one of the
reasons why I got hepatitis and [ __ ]
would be a little onion and potatoes I
get with the Phoenix why see my tomatoes
came out either this couple they're from
Pennsylvania they always are I thought
that's our pencils were made you know
that is good Hershey chocolate like that
what was the country issue then he was
like it's real
no I wasn't country the city in Florida
Gainesville you feel the real word you
think I was born bro
sounds like a bro term University
Florida what does that mean maybe one of
the schools is there a bigger school
maybe that's why we're talking about it
because of the schools I think is uber
support how funny you think about the
old term so a couple of the name is Lee
late and I already know the ethnicity
that's a couple that's the program
that's one person that's the girlfriend
no Liam no its lien
and greedy nananananana I remember Ella
they live beneath
lands home in the basement this is what
the home looks like that was forced like
that's my friends oh that's not good
super bulky so yes they don't have a
rest room down in the basement where
they live so they funnier and you know a
pan ku and bucket
why don't the gulps dish because we
build an outhouse I know I don't know
why
build it but the reason why they don't
go through they don't want to bother her
parents because don't come up we're
taking no fishes leigh-anne
no mo pisses in the bathroom so here's
LAN oh that's a man of faith look look
at her she sucked up like crazy she's
buying her lower lip words just
disguising it like you know what if I do
this they won't know me in the future
sure duckfaces has your business look at
that words are bottom lip are she's
pouting upside down it's upside down pal
she's biting that [ __ ] cuz she's on meth
I'm getting sad looking at her face she
looks like she could have been pretty I
was just thinking that she felt too much
[ __ ] tape we should say oh if she
didn't do meth he shouldn't look like me
she didn't do that did she look at me
she I know she looked at the other one
that [ __ ] isn't a lot of movies a hot
one while she was hot
Radio Curran oh yeah a little bit yeah
no sucked in Natrona no more than miesha
tate
obviously initiative judicata then this
is Grady and you look like a [ __ ]
grave so there's two sorry here and poop
a bucket so one stories from the cops
and the other stories from Grady I'll
believe the cop
so the cops are saying that Leanne got
into a fight with her boyfriend who
they've been together for ten years
they got into a fight and they claimed
that when he went to sleep she doused
him with gasoline and then set him on
fire with a kitchen match she was
probably cold and then I don't have a
toilet you don't got a heater wait did
you just say kitchen match what's a
kitchen match I feel like I didn't know
kitchens had matches just for the
kitchen it is a long one the wood water
I remember those I thought those were
Christmas matches [ __ ] seasonal
matches I thought those on yeah I
thought I thought those were like Jewish
candle matches not using in the candle
oh hey I think I you're right could you
say I have to lie to others and you had
to stick away up in the Soyuz that
according to police and so the mattress
caught on fire and so did the lower part
of his body that's the important part
for guys if she must have regretted her
decision because then she grabbed the
get a Burin like too much fire to a fire
well this is mentioned urine I'm not
sure looks like number one bucket number
two bucket I think so
but then one you gotta go both at the
same time right wait is there bathroom
break they don't have them it's only
upstairs and moms won't let him use it I
mean they'll have a bathroom isn't it
you don't have a bathroom Oh
can they live what they have but she's
got a kitchen she's got a fancy kitchen
match and a bottle of gas a mat and a
bottle of gas so they just [ __ ] in the
pudding idea of this house of disgust
what year is this something that annoys
you just [ __ ] in the oven - I don't know
it's a nasty habit that's of anything
well the restroom they probably don't
have a kitchen you know there was the
kitchen back in the gun was the gas down
there yeah sure gastly I'm Dan Leanne
well I'm fuck-ups this isn't 1,400
Europe why are they still [ __ ] in
buckets Grady look kind of normal does
he works hard and she spends his money
on math that's the story from the car
he's with her because she's crazy and
you know crazy girls give the best blow
jobs
that's why are you still with her you
know about that ha ha ha ha ha ha ha you
know what there's so many crazy girls in
this world right and guys stay with them
for like ever
you've been with her for 10 years what
do you think the reason is she's not a
three-horse she [ __ ] little more
fired that [ __ ] she's not going to dig
really good about the deficit uh yeah
she was rushed to the hospital she was
in critical condition he burned 25 to 30
percent of his body but the police say
that his injuries aren't
life-threatening oh cool he was strong
enough to wake up and speak to this
newspaper and so when he was being to
the newspaper from his hospital bed he
was telling them that the entire
incident was his fault what so his story
rejected the crazy [ __ ] she still wants
those blows out that's telling me you
can't understand she can't go to jail
I let myself on fire pissed on myself
Sarla
so his story is that he was he was
completely drunk when he was trying to
fix a weed whacker and that he ended up
filling the gasoline on his lower body
and he caught on fire when he lit a
match for a cigarette that's a great
idea like I'm dressed and gasps God
really looks like he was saying that if
it wasn't for his girlfriend that things
would have been a lot worse
that she saved his lower half by using
the urine
yeah both [ __ ] looks a bit awesome
like my crotch meant of melted issue
didn't throw the urine on me so why does
the police have such a different story
that is my question
yeah did they have to hurt and I
[ __ ] this what happened they ended
up arresting her and she got out on a
$100 bail what are the dollars what the
final Oh is the amount of her sales
using about 10% of the total so that
being this close of [ __ ] thousand I
don't even know if that cover is [ __ ]
a jaywalking ticket in LA hundred
dollars well Pennsylvania so they're
going to have to go to court and speak
to a judge and that's when Grady is
going to tell the judge his side of the
story and that's when the judge has to
determine if she's going to get charged
it sounds like a case of boyfriend abuse
because if it was reversed I could
totally see that the guy beat the [ __ ]
out of a girl and she's in the hospital
and she's like oh no I understand I just
want to be back with my husband ran into
a door yep that's the same [ __ ] that
just happened right now she's an abuse
of that [ __ ] and he was saying about
land he said that quote land has never
been in trouble in her life she is in no
way shape or form a criminal she's not
violent and would never hurt anybody she
didn't do anything - listen to yourself
for all men stand up what the puncher on
a job and leave that [ __ ] you must stop
don't take a chance boy Howard you're
independent you're strong you don't need
no woman all right go out there and
leave her take your market cords
backpack you don't need her all right
you are confident special and you are
man see this is this is a new era
okay guys are [ __ ]
come on guys hey you guys want to stock
any of us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and all kinds of stuff
for more videos
[Music]